et maintenant
m
ouais si l'amiral philippe de gaulle
amiral bon soir soit amiral m'enfin bon
soin d'enfants ferme tac pourquoi
mélanger l'huile légal
non amira vous l'avez vous la légion
d'honneur beau toutefois la hausse en
séance qu'il a fait il a porté la légion
d'honneur
alors qu'il n'a pas ouais moi je le
dénonce à voir étendu le cheveu très
très court en quarantaine bien alors
qu'ils évoluent bonsoir
à 82 ans vous devenez une star une star
de l'édition en révélant votre père sous
un jour inédit
le premier tome de deux goals mon père
dont vous êtes venu parler ici à la fin
du mois d'octobre s'est vendu à 500
mille exemplaires 5 arte compromis
l'exemplaire
fait rare dans l'émission de me jour et
le deuxième tome part et il se vend
mieux donc encore bravo je pense que les
faire un million au minimum avec les
deux tomes voilà est-ce que vous êtes
heureux tout à fait oui puisque c'est un
témoignage rage que j'ai un c'est un
témoignage qui va porter j'en suis
heureux je suis heureux que michel
tauriac
mais poser les questions de telle
manière que il me il m'incitait à parler
de ce que j'avais gardé en réserve parce
que c'était la réserve de mes parents
aussi de mon père et de ma mère j'ai lu
le dossier à fond et son père était
président c'est bien long alors non
c'est vrai que dans votre famille on est
on est très pudique votre père par
exemple naître et n'y ait personne en
public même pas votre mère et quand
votre père meurt vous vous penchez sur
son corps c'est la première fois
d'ailleurs que vous le voyez sans
cravate et voulu toucher l'arrière de la
tête pour voir si la lame la même base
que vous dire que jamais de votre vie
vous n'aviez touché la tête de votre
père n'ont jamais de ma vie sauf mort
rendue sur sur la couche sur lequel on
l'avait mis ainsi gelé touchée et
constater que nous avions le même mais
pl - endroit alors donc deux goals mon
père tome 2 le retour couvre les dix
dernières années de la vie du général de
son retour au pouvoir en 58 jusqu'à sa
mort
alors ce qui est extraordinaire c'est
quand il s'est installé l'elysée il
n'aime pas l'elysée
ils trouvent ça et riquet il dit qu'il
ya pas de vue c'est à dire
qu'effectivement ce qui les met dans un
château c'est qu'on puisse le voir de
loin et là il dit que finalement il a
encastré dans la rue du faubourg
saint-honoré et ça lui plaît pas du tout
il pense à un moment aller s'installer
au château de vincennes il y avait trop
de travaux à faire tout à fait ça aura
été très difficile et à des murs qui
font plusieurs mètres d'épaisseur pour
faire passer des conduites électriques
ou d'un conduites d'eau traitée vie
c'est pas évident en effet bien alors
donc quand vos parents arrivent à
l'elysée
il apporte le style de vie très
spartiate de la propriété que vous avez
s'appelle la boisserie pas de gaspillage
chez vous un de gaulle tenait à tout
payer
il éteignit les lumières quand ils
sortaient des pierres oui mais c'était
aussi la culture de son milieu tant de
son côté à 8 que du côté de ma mère ce
qui est extraordinaire avec votre père
aussi c'est que par exemple quand il
quand ils allaient dans un hôtel et
qu'il était invité
il demandait le montant de la facture et
il donnait une somme équivalente au
personnel en pourboires c'est tout à
fait vrai vous êtes exactement pareil
parce que un jour vous travaillez avec
michel pleau riac sur les deux bouquins
et puis son ordinateur explose parce que
bon il est plein de données et vous lui
faites un chèque pour qu'ils se
rachètent le même ordinateur
mais pourquoi vous at il dit cela il n'a
pas accepté ce chèque est alors ce qui
est extraordinaire aussi avec l'amiral
camp quand il était question de droits
d'auteur par exemple vous lui avait
proposé de partager les droits d'auteur
avec lui à 50/50 quoi ne s'est pas tout
à fait cela mais chez 100 et proche
alors vous raconter donc dans ce livre
leur politique du général là à commencer
par la réconciliation franco allemande
il invite le chancelier adenauer en 1958
à la boisserie ce qui était
extraordinaire parce que c'était 13 ans
finalement après après la libération
après l'occupation après la déportation
et à ce moment là il ya deux personnes
de la boisserie deux aides ménagères qui
refuse de servir le chancelier adenauer
oui lui n'était alsacienne la seconde
était lorraine et avait ressenti de
langue française entièrement est
ressentie l'invasion allemande comme une
invasion galette
il invite khrouchtchev deux ans plus
tard en 1960 il dit à khrouchtchev
quelque chose de très prémonitoire il
dit le capitalisme le communisme tout ça
sera rattrapé par la technologie et ça
sera le mondialisme c'est à dire qu'il
ya plus de quarante ans il avait déjà
sept notionnels technologie va dépasser
toutes les théories
philosophique ou qu'on avait pu
concevoir auparavant certaines datant de
alors votre père était quand même sur
amiral de la disparition du communisme
il disait d'ailleurs toujours la russie
il disait pas l'urss et il disait la
russie boira le communisme comme le
buvard bois lancre ses dires il était
persuadé non seulement la disparition du
communisme mais aussi de la
réunification de l'allemagne
il l'avait dit à l'époque que la visite
d'adenauer l'anglais comme un vrai vrai
destin historique un oui c'est une une
analyse historique il en avait
l'habitude il faisait aussi des analyses
opérationnel les calculs opérationnel en
1940 pour savoir si la grande bretagne
pouvait résister ou non alors on disait
que votre père était visionnaire m'enfin
sur l'algérie l'a été moins visionnaire
il a été beaucoup plus pragmatique parce
que vous infirmez complètement dans
votre bouquin la thèse selon laquelle de
gaulle avait tout prévu
depuis je vous ai compris jusque aux
accords d'evian celle qu'on a souvent
dit qu'en fait il avait joué un double
jeu quand il disait pas du tout mais si
je vais pas le double jeu alors je vous
ai compris vive l'algérie française
c'est-à-dire qu'ils pensaient en 58 que
l'algérie pouvait rester française il
est devenu soir mostaganem
oui mais il est revenu voir ce qui se
passait en algérie et là il est tombé
sur un désarroi total de la rébellion
algérienne qui a envoyé des émissaires
en se disant si général de gaulle
revient nous sommes perdus autant
arrêter la rébellion tout de suite ils
ont envoyé des émissaires et en même
temps il voyait sur toutes les places en
particulier à mostaganem où il y avait
beau match très grande majorité de
musulmans et l'a entendu tout le monde
crier algérie français il s'est dit
peut-être moi je pense que c'est trop
tard mais peut-être y at-il une chance
alors je vais l'essayer
on va voir à l'accueil et il a mis au
dessus avec le plan de constantine c'est
à dire la maîtrise des opérations
reprendre le
le dessus sur le terrain militairement
le les construire des hlm des ports des
aérodromes des routes des écoles
on ya mis tout dessus il y avait plus un
sou pour la métropole
tout était sur l'algérie au bout d'un an
il a vu que ça n'arrivait pas il
n'arrivait pas à faire basculer les
algériens de notre côté du côté français
parce que les français malgré la bonne
volonté de la plupart à partir du moment
où vous êtes obligé de vous livrer à des
opérations de police à faire des
vérifications d'identité à rentrer dans
les maisons ou les villages même les
gens qui sont pour vous finissent par
être exaspéré ou vexé et par conséquent
voulait retourner contre eux et la
population algérienne était en train
progressivement de plus en plus de ces
cartes est de nous sinon d'être contre
nous alors au bout d'un an il a vu que
ça ne marchait pas et au bout de 18 mois
il a dit donc je vais essayer une
algérie algérienne mais en le disant à
chaque fois dans une conférence de
presse il la trompait personne tous les
trois mois et une conférence de presse
qui durera 1h30 personne ne le faisait
il est déçu amiral par les pieds noirs
qui ont refusé de partager le pouvoir et
ils pensent d'ailleurs que ils se sont
suicidés en fait avec le wave y penser
ça pensé que c'était un suicide
et après ils se sont rapatriés ou à
patrouiller en panique en laissant tout
le
front de libération nationale ne
souhaitait pas le départ d
des pieds noirs car il se rendrait bien
compte qu'ils avaient besoin de leur
savoir faire technique et administratif
pour démarrer un autre état et cet été
une des raisons ce départ 10 ans de la
ruine de la librairie après le départ
des français
votre père n'est jamais retourné en
algérie après jamais jamais un père
n'est jamais retourné en algérie
voilà alors vous raconter aussi amiral
la première bombe atomique française
qu'on a appelée facilement la bombinette
leur rappeler la bombinette le canard
enchaîné
oui moi le canard enchaîné mais c'est
fait pour rire le canard enchaîné ce
poids là encore autre chose
oui donc l'ambassadeur soviétique dit au
général de gaulle si nous occupons
hambourg
vous ne bougerait pas car on enverra une
bombe sur marseille et de gaulle répond
à ce moment là maintenant et
l'ambassadeur nous mourrons ensemble
voilà parce que ce qui lui passe que
j'enverrai une bombe jeanine grade et
une autre sur moscou et jean ils ont
bien compris la france redevenait à ce
moment là et c'est assez fort parce que
la france redevenait à ce moment là une
puissance mondiale ce qu'elle allait
cesser d'être lors de la défaite de 1940
quoi c'est vrai la france n'existait
plus internationalement
bien que à la fin de la guerre en 45
elle avait plus de monde sur le terrain
contre les allemands que les anglais
ouais vous raconter aussi amiral les
attentats qui ont été dirigées contre
votre père notamment celui du petit
clamart qui a été sans doute un des plus
périlleux dans la dizaine qui ont eu
lieu et alors après la fusillade au
petit-clamart il sort de la voiture il
dit cette fois c'était en jean et il
ajoute ils ont vraiment tirer comme des
cochons chez tout à fait jour et bodmer
a dit c'est extraordinaire votre merdier
à ce moment là juste après l'attentât
l'était avec votre caravane a dit
j'espère que les poulets n'ont rien et à
ce moment là il ya les deux flics qui se
regardent et en fait c'était c'était des
poulets qui était dans le coffre de la
voiture
elle se fait du souci pour les poulets
n'est d'après jean-marc avec pompidou à
la boisserie et l'anecdote est
authentique
ses interprétations et erronée mais
l'imitation est très mauvaise alors vous
parlez aussi amiral de l'antisémitisme
supposé du général de gaulle alors voulu
d'abord qu'il était dreyfusards comme
son père il avait pris la défense de
dreyfus
il disait volontiers en parlant des
juifs c'est la communauté la plus
intelligente de la terre mais ce qui est
assez qui supportait pas qu'on
culpabilise le peuple français au nom du
martyr juif c'est quelque chose qui les
français se sont quand même battu les
armes à la main contre un système qui
lui voulait sinon exterminer les juifs
du moins les chasser oui les français
sont battus les armes sont battus comme
amiral de gamme un peu la vision
gaulliste ce à dire que les français se
sont battus par nagui avec 1 90% des
français qui n'ont rien foutu bahia ils
ont attendu 190 % ou plus sont plus
complets seraient enfin il ya eu quand
même quelques résistants à quelques
centaines de milliers de gens qui les
ont aidés qui donc aurait ce risque est
quelque chose qu'on vous dit qu'ils
voulaient pas qu'on culpabilise le
peuple français au nom du martyr juif
c'est au nom de légende police parce
qu'en fait c'est vrai que les français
sont quand même des choses à se
reprocher par rapport à cette époque les
français ne sont pas antisémites ils
l'ont jamais été
nous croyons dans les années 30 il va
essayer de les culpabiliser ça mon père
est une d'ailleurs de personnes ce soit
du côté opposé aussi mon père ne mettait
pas qu'on culpabilise les français si
quelqu'un a essayé de le faire même
temps qu'elle et dévots un nom ils
disaient que c'étaient des bourgs de
temps en temps ils étaient ils étaient
des veaux il s'avachissait voulait rien
quand votre père est arrivé au pouvoir
il a trouvé maurice papon qui était en
poste et qui avaient été blanchis par
deux jurys de résistants notoire mais
lui qui savait ce qui s'était passé
pendant la guerre pourquoi là pourquoi
l'at-il garder papon papon était en
préfet de police de paris et par qui il
faisait son métier donc on l'a laissé
et puisqu'il faisait son métier dont il
allait enfin d'affectation et puisque
les deux jurys de la résistance car il a
aussi rendu des services à la résistance
ne l'avait pas condamné pour mon père
qu'il n'avait pas de raison de le
condamner plus un autre parce que ils
savaient très bien mon père ce qui
s'était passé en france il ne voulait
pas susciter des polémiques indéfinie
des uns contre les autres
vous savez s'il avait fallu prendre à
partie tous les gens qui ont transporté
des juifs d'un endroit où d'un autre en
france je précise alors à ce moment là
il fallait inculpé les conducteurs de
bus les chemins de fer etc
vous savez beaucoup de gens qu'il aurait
fallu inculpé en france à ce moment là
encore que et je précise
les français ont beaucoup plus protégé
les juifs que ils n'en ont livré ce y en
a qui ont été livrés aux et dont
beaucoup ont pu échapper avec souvent la
complicité de la police
alors quand la guerre des six-jours
éclate en 1967 le général de gaulle
prend ses distances avec l'état d'israël
est également la gold amer qui dirigeait
l'état d'israël dit ceux qui ne sont pas
avec nous sont contre nous et c'est là
que votre père à cette phrase qui lui a
beaucoup été reproché vous le savez en
parlant des juifs il a dit l'egypte un
peuple d'élite dominateur et sûr de soi
alors il parait dites vous dans votre
bouquin dans sa bouche c'est un
compliment mais ça a été vécue par les
juifs de france l'opposition s'est
immédiatement emparé cette phrase pour
la tronquer mais vous savez à l'époque
ça faisait pas tellement de polémique
des spécialistes les six 6 mois je me
suis un mirage
je me souviens d'un dessin toujours un
dessin dans l'express de tim grands
dessinateurs où il montrait un juif dans
un camp de concentration
avec marquez dessous un peuple d vite
dominateurs et sûr de soi c'était si
c'était julien deux décennies avant que
de gaulle combattez qui ouais hein
il combattait pour pour empêcher bien
sûr mais vous voulez dire que la votre
père ayant été le général de gaulle à
londres
il me permettre de dire ça il ya qu' il
est
quand madame golda meyer est d'abord
passée aux états unis avant la guerre
préventive pas l'état d'israël s'est
livré et puis les états unis étaient en
campagne électorale présidentielle
les américains sont très mécontents
quand on les dérange au moment d'une
campagne présidentielle
pour eux c'est capital donc ils n'ont
rien dit à madame kolda meyer madame
golda meyer et passer ensuite en france
elle a demandé l'avis du général de
gaulle le général de gaulle a dit je
suis opposé à toute l'espèce de conflits
au moyen orient
aussi bien vous l'état israélien que
tous les autres états autour
et quand cette ce conflit a éclaté il a
arrêté tout ce que nous fournissions aux
uns et aux autres et mais d'un côté
comme de l'autre
car il ne voulait pas de conflit au
moyen orient
il est effréné il pensait il à dire
madame kolda meyer vous allez vous êtes
plus forts dont vous aller conquérir des
territoires
mais après comme vous allez faire une
coalition contre vous de gens qui ne
sont pas d'accord entre eux
vous serez obligé un jour ou l'autre de
l'évacuer et vous allez être gêné jeu
vous approuve pas dans cette c'est à ce
moment là que madame kolda meyer qui
avait une fille était une femme de
détermination et les amis a dit bon bain
puisque vous n'êtes pas pour nous vous
êtes contre nous voilà c'est tout de
même un peu abusif comme raisonnement
1 mon père a dit mais c'est un peuple
d'élite mais en ce moment il est sûr de
soi et dominateur voilà donc on arrive
amiral en 1968 alors là votre père en
1968 il faut le dire est un petit peu
dépassé par les événements il ya une
crise mondiale a à ce moment là qui
touchent les étudiants du monde entier
mais lui pensait que l'abondance la
protection sociale les avancées
technologiques mettrait la france à
l'abri et en fait il s'aperçoit à ce
moment là que c'est sérieux en france 68
et il se reproche à lui-même d'avoir un
petit peu donner trop d'importance à sa
politique étrangère il dit le seul
responsable c'est moi c'était assez
extraordinaire parce qu'ils étaient
capables de reconnaître et pertinents
fachan oui ces erreurs et vous et là
vous lui dit un truc tout à fait rare
vous lui dites pas pas il faut bien voir
qu à terme votre règne est fini
j'aurais jamais cru j'ai appris ça en
lisant votre le deuxième trajet mais
j'aurais jamais cru que vous osiez dire
ça à votre père mais c'est aussi à ce
moment là j'étais capitaine de vaisseau
j'avais presque l'âge des ministres
maintenant vous lui dites pas pas il
faut bien voir qu à terme votre règne
votre règne est fini et c'est la
première fois que vous lui jeter comme
ça une vérité à la tête
oui mais en réalité il a bien réalisé
ouais moi je commence à être lassé du
peuple français et le peuple français
est sans doute le fait le vrai alors
c'est très très touchant dans votre
bouquin c'est quand vous lui jeter cette
vérité à la tête pour la première fois
vous entendez de sa part un aveu de
faiblesse c'est moi la première fois en
tous les cas que que je vis quelque
chose de tel au sujet du général de
gaulle il vous dit ne me décourage pas
oui il a sans doute dit la même chose à
ma mère parce que je reste grave on
était à 2
lui dire directement extraordinaire en
temps le général de gaulle peu perçu
dire ne le décourage passé mais ne me
décourage pas oui je ne peux quand même
pas lécher la france n'importe quand à
n'importe qui et là ya le fameux
l'épisode de baden baden donc est une
ville allemande qui à l'époque était
encore une garnison française
alors on a souvent comparé le voyage à
baden baden à départ de louis saez la
fuite à varennes pour vous pas du tout
vous dites c'est un stratagème c'est à
dire c'est pas du tout une fuite c'est
en fait une façon de faire subir un
électrochoc au français est une façon
aussi de désarçonner l'adversaire c'est
vrai tout chef doit avoir une manoeuvre
1 dont il ne fait part à personne mais
en même temps c'était une menace un
clairement exprimée pour quoi allécher
massue qui était le plus fracassant de
touche
s'il avait voulu esquiver il serait pas
passée chez mathieu dont closky parano
ce qui part à baden vous dites c'est un
stratagème en fait pour désarçonner
l'adversaire que vous vouliez qui lui
fit d'autres oui le mation massue a
longtemps dit maintenant il est mort il
peut pas dire le contraire mais il a
toujours dit que le général de gaulle
avait perdu les pédales et qu'il était
venu en fait à baden baden pour chercher
du secours pour chercher de l'aide parce
qu'il était complètement découragé il
était prêt à abandonner le pouvoir et
que lui massue a dû lui remonter le
moral
cette semaine dans le journal le point
il ya le colonel richard qui est l aide
de camp de massue qui est pas d'accord
avec la version que vous avez dans votre
bouquin il dit que lui il était là bas
il a il sait que massu a eu du mal à
convaincre votre père de rester au
pouvoir qu'en fait votre père voulait
démissionner et qui a eu deux entretiens
et non pas un comme vous dites dans
votre bouquin et qu'il a fallu vraiment
le convaincre de rester au pouvoir
vous lui répondez quoi ces conneries
charles richard qui n'était peut-être
pas gaulliste au départ joint à dire
donnez-les au collet dans le richard a
voulu défendre son patron ouais
après des ouvrages comme dit rappelle
pierre messmer qui ont été dites et
longtemps après ouais selon sa version
avec mathieu a écrit ses mémoires
présent après oui bien alors voilà c'est
ça pèse de gaulle mon père c'est le tome
2 c'est passionnant parce que ça touche
et une période plus récente encore que
le tome 1 c est publié chez plon
alors vous tordez le coup a beaucoup de
rumeurs dans ce bouquin amiral et puis
aussi un certain nombre de citations
donc on va voir les situations qui sont
de votre père ou celles qui ne sont pas
de votre père et on va faire une
interview pas pad